[Musique]
bonjour à tous nos amis à poil et à
plumes et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de kéfé la bestiole aujourd'hui
nous allons nous intéresser à un oiseau
à la tête dure le pic épeiche alors
petit rappel de la consigne pour les
nouveaux venus sur la chaîne je vous
proposer une vidéo courte montrant le
comportement d'un oiseau viendra ensuite
un quiz qui vous proposera 4
explications de ce comportement à vous
de choisir la bonne allez je ne vous
retiens pas plus longtemps c'est parti
des idées sur la raison de ce
comportement si vous n'en avez pas je
n'ai pas grave vous pourrez choisir
parmi les réponses suivantes alors qui
est fait la bestiole petit a il délimite
son territoire tout en essayant
d'attirer les femelles du coin c'est du
tambourinage petit B il a confondu un
poteau avec un tronc d'arbre et il
essaie d'y trouver des insectes cachés
sous les Corses c'est du martèlement
petit C il renforce son bec en tapant
sur un objet le plus dur possible c'est
du renforcement petit d c'est le nouveau
batteur du groupe de Death metalavien de
la région les Black Crows
alors je vais vous laisser réfléchir et
pendant ce temps je vous remets la vidéo
alors comme d'habitude pensez à bien
garder l'environnement de l'oiseau car
ce sont souvent ces petits détails qui
donnent des indices pour trouver la
bonne réponse
et voici l'heure du quiz alors qui fait
la bestiole la bonne réponse était
[Musique]
là c'est ce qu'on appelle du
tambourinage
[Musique]
chaque espèce a son rythme de
tambourinage spécifique souvent
réglementé de petites vocalisations
entre les séries de coups on peut donc
différencier les espèces rien qu'à leur
manière de tambouriner
alors attention tous les pics ne
tambournent pas le pivert par exemple ne
s'y adone quasiment jamais pourtant
bourriner les pies ont un équipement
très spécialisé leur crâne et leur bec
sont renforcés pour supporter les chocs
répétés et il dispose même d'un conduit
osseux supplémentaire qui fait le tour
de la boîte crânienne dans laquelle
vient s'insérer leur langue cette langue
très longue fait tout le tour de la tête
pour venir s'attacher sur le front on
pense que cette cavité osse
supplémentaire joue aussi un rôle dans
l'amortissement des chocs du haut
tambourinage
[Musique]
petit adaptation supplémentaire la queue
elle est constituée de plumes courtes
très rigide sur lesquelles le pic va
s'appuyer lorsqu'il s'accroche au tronc
d'un arbre elle lui permet de rester
stable sans effort ce qui est grandement
à la précision des coups de bec et
quelle précision lors du tambourinage
les pics frappent toujours le même point
sans jamais dévier d'ailleurs c'est
extrêmement important si par malheur il
n'était pas bien centré sur leur cible
il prendrait le risque de manquer leur
coup et de dévier la tête ce qui vu la
force des coûts pourrait probablement
leur fracturer les os du crâne voire
même des vertèbres mais attention les
pics n'utilisent pas leur bec que pour
du tambourinage ils font aussi ce qu'on
appelle du Martel man le martèlement
c'est l'action de taper sur un tronc à
la recherche de nourriture
principalement des petites bestioles
cachées sous l'écorce des arbres il
creuse des petits trous et envoie
ensuite leur langue ornée de barbe
piquantes en palet les insectes qui s'y
sont cachés
et non au cas où vous vous le demandiez
les pics ne sont pas suffisamment
stupides pour confondre un arbre avec un
poteau le martèlement s'effectue
uniquement sur des troncs jamais sur des
poteaux qui sont totalement dépourvues
des corps c'est donc parfaitement
inutiles en termes de recherche
d'insectes oui les oiseaux savent faire
la différence je ne serai pas du tout
étonné qu'il soit aussi capable de
déterminer qu'un poteau métallique
résonne bien mieux qu'un tronc et donc
le son porte plus loin si le tambourine
sur le poteau
après tout leur but c'est d'être entendu
de très loin de la même manière vous ne
verrez jamais un pic essayer de creuser
son lit dans un poteau métallique les
pics choisiront toujours un arbre Tron
suffisamment large pour y mettre leur
nichés pas un truc tout fin sans écorce
et ses nids seront réutilisés plus tard
par d'autres espèces comme des chouettes
par exemple allez c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir suivi cet
épisode et à bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures avec des plumes
[Musique]